this is the world's largest party on ice
we are the largest charitable fishing
contest in the entire world we have
upwards of 10,000 people out here and
we're all supporting local charities the
entire thing is volunteer run we have
approximately 80 volunteers come out
they take 40 hawkers out go to guys or
two people by two people and they punch
holes / - this year it was two and a
half hours for 19 thousand holes in the
ice we do give away 150 prizes for the
top hundred fifty fish but number one is
our the truck your choice but we do
intersperse big prizes all through there
so even if you catch a smaller fish you
might be looking to get bumped down on
the board because you're waiting all day
for the three hours to get pushed to
that big expensive fish house or maybe a
four-wheeler we have caught about
thousand fish each year but we are a
live release tournament we do release
every fish that we catch eighty-five
percent of the fish do survive
well I meet plenty of people who can't
believe let alone that we go out on ice
alone but then when you punch twenty
thousand holes and get ten thousand
extra people out there they don't
believe you it is quite the experience
you forget you're on the ice once you
get this many people out here because it
becomes a small city other people think
that all it's freezing out here and they
think Minnesotans are crazy out here and
all that but it's a lot of fun for other
people younger generations are getting
into it and I'm going to find time out
here
[Music]
you